remember remember the fifth of November
crap I should have done this earlier in
the month
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there folks this is a patreon
sponsored review and one that I am
rather happy to get to do so I have I
got commissioned to take a more thorough
look at the film adaptation of V for
Vendetta
now I've actually talked about this film
before twice in fact but only in pretty
narrow capacity it came a scene from it
or a segment rather came up in a list
that I did else where I'm not gonna say
what that list was because that'll
reveal too much or Leone and also
there's a scene that came up on a
nitpick rant and I'll point those out as
I get to them also before I get into
this I will point out that I have not
read the original work in its entirety
Alan Moore I feel at his best is an
excellent comic book writer however he
can be just a lot and I'm not always in
the mood for his particular brand so I
I've read bits towards the front of it
and I do own it but I haven't read all
of it so this is a this is my view
strictly of the film and I am NOT going
to be judging it as an adaptation or
taking it to task for any of those kinds
of changes so if you take issue with the
film because of what was changed cool
just realize I ain't gonna bring that up
so anyways I remember going to the
theater to this one I felt empowered
coming out of this and that's saying
something there there are lots of things
that I'm used to feeling coming out of
films you know energized drained
[Music]
amused if there's a really good comedy
maybe my cheeks hurt a bit but there are
some things that only a handful of films
have made me feel wonder triumph
powerful this movie made me feel
powerful because the way that it
delivers its message that power is found
in the people who make a stand and it
doesn't even necessarily matter who they
are and that collectively we we do
matter which is the note that it very
much ends on I I still enjoy that
message and I sure as heck connected to
it when this thing came out originally I
think easily the scene stealer here is
Hugo Weaving as V the amount that he is
able to bring to a part where he has no
face and it's not even like it's an
equivalent to voice acting because you
know even a voice actor for like an
animation part of whatever it won't be
their face but there will be a face
emotive bringing across you know what
the vocalization implies none of that no
face and he delivers such a perfectly
rounded and engaging character it's
phenomenal and I'm really glad they
never show his face I'm so glad they
never did that but it's it really is
astounding and hats off to him for both
for not just doing the voice work for
being on set in a mask when it could
have just been a stuntman or a stand-in
for the entire shoot audience never
would've known oh it's really good and
then we've gotta Natalie Portman this I
think is one of her best performances I
put this up there with Black Swan and
the professional I first of all at least
to my American ears
the accent seems pretty good fools me I
I don't notice that it's not her accent
that pretty much immediately she does a
really good job of giving believable
layers to someone who can see what Vee
is trying to go for and can maybe even
empathize with him a bit but is also
completely put off and scared by
everything going on around her the
journey she goes through from the
beginning to the end and how her
experiences transform par I find to be
incredibly believable and incredibly
human some other standout Stephen Fry is
great the detectives are great honestly
the entire cast John Hurt oh man he was
so good being this angry petty man at
the top of the pile oh he was good like
everybody the entire cast is phenomenal
everybody is really good at delivering
what it is they are here to do and it's
I was almost gonna say it's not easy to
make what is effectively a terrorist
heroic except I'm not sure that's true I
think it actually could be very easy
depending on who it is they're taking
acts of terror against and how charming
issues to make them here's what I'll say
it's not easy to make a terrorist
someone you would root for while at the
same time not sugarcoating what it is
they do or what they're like which I
don't feel this did overly you know VIII
is violent and vicious and potentially
damaging the very society's trying to
break free you know he may very well
believe and the film may ultimately bear
out that he appears to be right about
what he's doing in his goals and how
he's going about it but especially early
on there is the distinct possibility
that he is making it worse
because the crackdowns that are going
that are going on and that gets
exemplified later on with what goes on
with kind of the montage of the young
girl who spray paints his symbol and
gets gunned down in the street I don't
think that was any part of these master
plan that that would happen
he probably knew it was possible though
and that's that's a heavy thing to deal
with and also you have to think about
what he put evey through and again he
may justify that and rationalize it but
freakin harsh and I feel like the film
is just judgemental enough towards him
in the way he was about what he's doing
he is the hero and the film is on his
side but I think there's there's enough
sort of holding back and not giving
total endorsement from start to finish
enough moments of doubt enough dips in
like is this really the way this needs
to happen moments across the film that
makes it not just going yeah blowing up
buildings great which I mean I suppose
some people could take it that way but I
I I feel like it it pulls back just
enough so that it's not coming across
like that so I alluded to having brought
up a couple of scenes a couple of
segments of the film before so the one
that I brought up in the nitpick rant is
the one scene that I do not like and if
I had the power I would excise from the
film and it's about the only thing I
would change about the film and that is
the Rookwood scene this is the scene
where the investigators trying to track
down Vee and figure out what the heck is
going on and why they get wind of
someone named Brookwood who you know
keeps to himself and he but he reaches
out and contacts them and he won't let
them come close stays two shadows and he
tells them about some of the details of
how this government came to power
now there's two things I really don't
like about this scene
one I think it's painfully obvious that
that is V in a different mask you know a
little convinced am i convincing latex
mask partly because he talks for so dang
long you pick up Hugo we Hugo Weaving
voice after a bit so that gets blown way
too early by my estimation but to and
more vitally none of this is information
that's worth stopping the story dead for
basically everything that gets said and
communicated to the audience and the
scene is all stuff that we already knew
or had enough of the pieces that we
could easily infer we certainly knew
that the government did this type of
thing to get into power but even if we
didn't know that exactly we've seen the
way that they wield power and so exactly
how they got there whether they trick to
the public or manufacture to crisis to
get themselves into power honestly it's
kind of irrelevant because how they
wield power now is enough of a reason
that they need to be toppled regardless
of how they got to power in the first
place so the fact that the film devotes
as many minutes of its runtime as it
does for an exposition dump that doesn't
actually give us any substantively
different information and that and what
little new information we get isn't
necessary to justify anything that's
going on plot wise chuck it it's
completely redundant and unnecessary
storytelling wise that scene shouldn't
be in there the other scene that I've
talked about before is the it's the
scene of evey in the cell and she starts
getting little notes little
communications through this crack in the
wall from a woman on the other side and
that woman is telling her story
the story of her life her love and the
destruction of all of it
by the current powers that be and the
list that I put this segment in was a
video that I did talking about movie
scenes that always make me cry
yeah that one hits me really hard for a
lot of reasons one because the story she
read she relays is very sad she's just
she was just a woman and at one point a
young girl trying to figure out herself
based on the fact that she felt pulled
towards other women meaning a woman
falling in love watching the world turn
against them having her wife disappear
being black bagged herself but what
truly breaks my heart about this scene
isn't what is describing but it's why
she's telling everyone cuz this is just
her reality this is just her history but
she's tell she's pushing these notes
through a crack in the wall not knowing
who's on the other side not even knowing
for certain if there is someone on the
other side but because someone has to
know someone has to know that someone
she someone has to at least have the
possibility of finding and hearing the
fact that she was here she was a person
and she was reduced to something much
lower than that somebody has to know
what is going on even if that person has
no power to do anything about it
and I and the fact that it ultimately
gets revealed that V is the one pushing
those notes through the other side
doesn't complete the racket because he
reveals that these stories and these
notes were provided to him he basically
was in Evie's place in a different
position a different location so that
doesn't wreck it for me at all
that scene is so powerful in terms of
relaying in short order the devastation
the life breaking impact of persecution
and bigotry because a woman loves
another woman I think that seems amazing
I think the movie as a whole is amazing
I think Hugo Weaving in Natalie Portman
have terrific chemistry she's actually
got really good chemistry pretty much
everyone she communicates with when
she's saying out with Stephen Fry when
she's talking with the would-be cops
with the investigators and I really do
enjoy the investigators the those actors
are very good as well which is which is
good because that could have been a slog
all the way through as it stands it's
only the real good scene that's a slog
but the rest of their stuff is really
interesting I like watching them trying
to piece together what's going on with
the B I know some people are critical of
the action scenes I think a lot of this
largely has to do with it being more
actioned up versus the original work and
obviously I can't speak to that I will
say that the the last sort of major
action set piece when V takes down
creedy's men is ridiculous in terms of
what is shown and in terms of some of
the visualization the the way the blood
spatter splatter is done and some of the
sound effects are rigged they're almost
Kurt
I'm not going to deny any of that but
I'm also gonna say I don't care because
the lead-in is V confronting these men
Creed II saying we've got guns and he
just goes no what you have is bullets
and the hope that when you're done
firing them I'm no longer standing and
I'm like oh that's so badass and then we
go through this ridiculous action scene
which I again I know is ridiculous but I
don't care because we led in with that
and it ends with him with his hands on
creavy's neck and you know Creed II
gasping why won't you die he says
because underneath this mask is an idea
and ideas are bulletproof I don't care
how easy it is this film
aand it as far as I'm concerned is that
cheesy yes don't care I love it I really
enjoy the rallying cry of this movie
this notion of you know when something's
wrong you have to do something I find
this film energizing and I think one of
the things I like about it is is it
feels righteous and empowering in a way
that does not necessarily demand a
violent response because while V himself
has made the decision to employ violence
and explosions to make its point I think
ultimately the note that it ends on is
much more if we make them hear us then
we are mighty not necessarily blow that
up I may be and maybe that's me trying
to square a circle so that I don't have
to cop to a film I really like possibly
being read as an endorsement of violent
action but I do think enough about the
presentation
and showing the value of all the all the
people who aren't V and what they do
does a lot to keep that in line and keep
that in check because you know the
people who march don't slaughter the the
police presence
they just keep marching v relies on
violence but the other people don't have
to and it's them we end with so I I feel
that that helps balance what otherwise
could have been a very problematic
message maybe other people still find it
problematic and I'm not necessarily sure
I can argue against that but there you
go V for Vendetta I still haven't read
the graphic novel I should but I do
really love this movie I think it looks
great I think it's paced great I think
the acting is phenomenal I love the heck
out of this have you rewatched it lately
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do as
well buttons links merch subscribe
patreon it's all down there click on
stuff it'll take you places or don't I'm
not running a fascist government I'm not
gonna tell you what you have to do you
make your own decisions because you are
the Council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]